the other day on my show somebody asked
me
how they can make themselves be happy
and they said they're always looking in
the mirror
saying i know i can choose to be happy
and i stopped and i said no you can't
you can't choose happy what you can do
is choose to do the things that are
gonna eventually lead to happiness so
what does that mean if you stare in
front of the mirror and go get happy get
happy it's gonna make you bananas but if
i choose in the morning as jacob says
put the donut down if i choose to
exercise if i choose to hug my my wife
and my kids and my buddy see
if i choose to go for a walk outside
when it's beautiful if i choose to put
my phone down and use his right if i
choose to do those things if i choose to
eat right whatever
it's going to lead me to be a little bit
more happy or if things go sideways it's
going to lead me to have a strong
foundation so i can deal with some of
that nonsense when it happens and if i
can't deal with it then i got a buddy
here who can help as well